I like that last one but if you if you
don't want to have a child with someone
just don't sleep with them like at the
end of the day we all know even
protection nothing's the only thing
that's 100 is abstinence so if you do
then you can't be mad at the other
person if you do have if you end up
pregnant like because you knew it was a
risk well and another thing is like we
only get pregnant like four days in the
month you're up so it's like
and and we have 41 forms of birth
control you couldn't try one like we
have so many options to not get pregnant
you can get an IUD of a 99 point
something percent chance would you not
say a lot of young women get pregnant
because we're not really taught I didn't
know to to get on anything you know I
don't know if a lot of women went for
the hair or taught from a young age
[Music]
I mean I just think I think 10 11 12.
did you have a choice you could have go
to doctor and get the pill just like
that your mom may feel concerned I just
I think that's just the lack of
accountability I'm sorry if you're if
you're born in the age of the internet
you don't have an excuse no like you you
can Google what like what happened I'm
sorry you can't tell me any 15 14 year
old doesn't know that if you have sex
you can get no you know but but you just
don't care and you make that choice
anyway that's that's your own fault I
feel like when parents don't talk about
sex and and anything school is not
enough you might feel shy asking your
parents and infants who might risk I
mean I I disagree I did 12 Years of
Catholic school I I grew up in like and
we had no teen pregnancies in my high
school
except maybe they're actually there
might have been one but she was kind of
not I don't know if she was telling that
there may there may be was one but like
no no confirmed
um was it a girl school or girls no it
was girls and guys it was like a mix
yeah but I just I just I think that a
lack of of knowledge is just an excuse
like I don't know how you can get to be
14 15 and not know if you have sex you
you get pregnant yeah you know but but
you just don't care
you're not Macho enough to fully
understand the risk you know what could
happen but I just feel like you know so
if someone if someone's 14 15 and they
shoot somebody yeah you don't think they
know what's gonna happen they know but
they don't I just feel like they're not
mature at that stage someone needs to be
more in control of them too much media
for that they they definitely notice
yeah
I think they know that maybe not
thinking about the long run in their
future but you still know whether you
decide to think about your future or not
whatever you're doing at a young age you
still know what can happen what the
consequences will be I feel like that's
too much too heavy to put on a 14 year
old yeah you know I mean yeah there's a
reason why if you were to mess with the
14 year old you go to jail because they
really can't make that sort of the state
kids
but I understand with parents they
should you know from I don't know like
you said your your parents uh you got to
have a conception from 12 or 13 or so
yeah that's fine they should you know do
that but to expect the 14 year old to
you know you have to expect to say Mom
let's go to doctor I want contraception
it's it's a lot
I mean it's an uncomfortable
conversation but but the parents should
say okay you know maybe we should get
you something maybe before we even
happened
on hormones at 13 4 15. I would just you
know start the conversation but you
should know your child when they might
be having all you know they're going
parties you just you as a parent I feel
like it's more of a responsibility for
you than a 14 year old to say Mom let's
get me contraception I'm doing it you
know what's interesting the more
contraception
um like
the more they put sex ed in schools like
the more people have sex so the more you
talk about kids with sex like like
before they started putting that in
schools like there's a large proportion
of high school students that graduated
as virgins yeah I don't agree talking a
lot today and so even that point about
and she said about
um parents giving contraception the
legal age isn't even 14.50 so you
shouldn't be having sex anyway yeah I'm
gonna go to their parents because they
know that they shouldn't because it's
not legal and also I was going to say is
that especially when it comes to
um learning about contraception and I've
got a conversation from my parents I
think it depends
so you have people you can actually talk
to again this is a very media driven
right now so you can explain something
on the Internet yeah which depends on
like I said your household
since I was close to my mom I'm close to
my mom yeah yeah so there's not a lot of
people like that so yeah your case is
cool there's a lot of people that yeah
especially at the age of 14 15 you
shouldn't be having a age because it's
illegal no yeah yeah so you're really
going to go to your parents and say oh
I'm having sex at this age also I
suppose if it's true if you're a boy it
might be a bit more it might not be as
bad as if it was a female saying I'm
having sex with a guy yeah at that age
but at the same time it's the same as
smoking a cigarette you're never gonna
go to a parent say that so I think with
sex none of us will go to our parents
and say is this safe enough even if I'm
17 it's I think smoking's a bit
different
or drinking alcohol well it's illegal
okay it's a bit different because
there's the what can come from it
is the impact of drinking the alcohol at
14 and smoking a cigarette is different
from having sex and getting pregnant but
parents it's very taboo like sex parents
treat sex like if it was illegal like
cigarette you can't come even if you're
17 talk to them I think it depends
Generations some parents also you've got
some parents that might not be able to
relay the information to their child so
they understand it because think about
if you for example if you had your first
child at 14 15. you may not be able to
relay that message to your child
effectively because you might not learn
something
so some people may not be able to go to
their child and say
XYZ so I'm saying yeah I have a question
do you guys think that a parent should
let their kid transition from like a boy
to a girl or girl to a boy at 14 15 16.
no no no no
I'll say no and the reason the reason
why I'll say no is because I think
um
trust me but um
I I think that's
um
APK is still developing at that age and
talking to your kid about transitioning
basically
changing from one sex to the other
is a huge thing you know
um so many things will happen and I
think the parent needs to let the child
to really get to understand their body
for what it is and then later on in life
they can then decide if if they want to
then they can then decide to do that but
I think at a very encouraging a child to
basically
change things yeah so does everyone
generally say no did anyone yeah so
generally yeah I'll let my child know
they should do that when you're not
though okay okay anyone no no yes is in
here okay so why do we let girls go on
birth control which changes their body
from a young age like 15 16. and can and
you can have your hormones can be
changed forever and never go back is
that with every form of pet control
um even even copper it has negative
effects on your uterus so you are
effectively changing their body what's
the hormonal change yeah like for
example it changes who you're attracted
to a lot of girls will go on birth
control and develop like different
conditions with their hormones where
they can't regulate them effectively
after like five ten years makes you gain
a lot of weight go ahead well you said
life is about Traders right as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible